i rarely do this but today i have
a really important confession to make
i've rethought my entire perspective on
equality
femininity female empowerment see i used
to believe that women deserved respect
because of all the incredible things
they do
and accomplish i looked to my wife as a
model for a woman who deserves respect
a wife a mother of three doctor
community member
a wonderful person but i have rethought
all of that
because of a new megan v stallion video
brilliantly titled thought
i was made aware of this video because
some of my viewers notified me the
reviewers of the video had said that
the song thought was directed at me to
which i responded what does thought mean
and also isn't megan the stallion the
woman who for some reason
has a middle name that means you when it
should actually just specify the
definite article
but then i watched her stunning music
video and
whole vistas of philosophy were made
available to me new revelations with
regard to human excellence
were divulged the light shone forth i
was converted
to megan v stallion's brilliant world
view
as balum's ass made to him known the
wishes of the divine
so too did megan the stallion's ass make
known to all of us
the platonic meaning of true womanhood
for truly
civilization has rarely been graced with
a poet of such magnificence a genius
of such magnitude an icon of such genius
i could go on and i will but first i
wish to share her
revelation and it is a revelation with
us all for megan
the stallion yes my friends the stallion
is not the mere definite article
but within you comes to share a message
and we can do little but gape in awe at
her astonishing
inspiring intellect insight
ah ye gods that we should have twerking
among us
such a paradigm of sheer perspicacity
sophistication
and enlightenment grateful we all should
be to live
in such a glorious time now to our
extraordinary
incandescent resplendent music video
[Applause]
hello look the women that
you accidentally trying to step on
are everybody that you depend on they
treat your diseases they cook your meals
they haul your trash drop your
ambulances they guard you while you
sleep
they control every part of your life
do not
buy odin's beard the heartbreaking
wisdom
i need shaking ass on my thigh post me a
pig finna make me a profit
[Music]
anvil the aristotelian insight
by thor's great hammer the extraordinary
non-objectification and empowerment
the originality the virtuosity the
percipience
the praise it is all too little we must
investigate the supreme quality
of megan the stallion's groundbreaking
work within e
the true shakespearean artistic fluidity
rhyming
thought with both profit and toxic
but also rhyming venom with dinner
and also somehow finding the room to use
the word
12 times 44 times 24 times
five times and the n word seven times
all
in just under three minutes and in this
song
we learn that megan the stallion will
soon at the shockingly prodigious age of
just 26
graduate from the prestigious texas
southern university with a degree in
health administration as she says
2021 finney graduate college
the true empowerment of this song hands
on my knees shaking
on my thought post me a pic final make
me
a prophet yes true female empowerment
is to be found in profiting from your
thought
the true beauty which lies within
exposed in the song
i walk around the house butt naked and i
stop at every mirror just to stare at my
own posterior
yes meaning is to be found in gazing
narcissist-like
into the gaping maw of your own
the true honor and love we ain't even
speaking
if the n-word ain't spendin yes indeed
true love and honor can only be found in
having sex with men
based purely on the amount of lucr they
spend on you yes a
thousand times yes hands on my knees
shaking
on my thought indeed indeed
after seeing this unbelievably brilliant
music video i actually respect
my own wife less today because she
decided to be
an actual doctor and went to college and
medical school
and residency rather than going to party
city
buying a hot doctor outfit and then
twerking for the pleasure of millions of
men while reserving her sexual favors
only for those who pay her the most
money
my wife she just did not understand the
true uniqueness of womanhood
instead opted to get married bear
children care for those children
hold a job rather than dressing up in a
public sanitation worker outfit and
running over fake conservative senators
in a garbage truck
truly megan v stallion has set forth an
awe-inspiring vision of femininity and
womanhood may we
all remember her contribution to
humanity as we forge forth
to ever greater civilizational heights
who's got two thumbs and wants you to
like and subscribe